bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct je suis ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir le bras de fer sur les
retraites c'était jour de manifestations
dans toute la France à l'appel
principalement de la CGT jour qu'a
choisi également le gouvernement pour
sortir du flou sur la méthode Elisabeth
borne lâche du lest sur le calendrier en
lançant un nouveau cycle de concertation
tandisque Emmanuel Macron lui brandi la
menace de la dissolution alors manœuvre
tactique ou un vrai signe d'apaisement
c'est notre grand débat dans un instant
notre grand témoin ce soir est rabbin
elle publie en cette rentrée littéraire
un livre jubilatoire il n'y a pas de
Hajar monologue contre l'identité chez
Grasset référence à Émile Ajar le
pseudonyme le double fictif de
l'écrivain Romain Gary en revisitant son
œuvre avec tendresse et surtout beaucoup
d'humour elle nous invite à nous
réinventer et à faire un pas vers
l'étranger qui est en nous delphine
nordviller est avec nous ce soir enfin
les parties prive de nos affranchis ce
soir un nouveau visage
le philosophe Pierre Henri tavoyau
plaide pour le retour du cumul des
mandats les séistes chlo et Ridel
revient sur la poussée de fièvre
identitaire un peu partout en Europe et
puis l'oeil sur le numérique de Delphine
Sabattier ce soir des douaniers
américains qui siphonnent les
smartphones des voyageurs voilà pour le
menu de ce vers ce soir
[Musique]
000 40 000 manifestants à Paris selon
les syndicats et beaucoup moins selon la
police mobilisation
d'asséphale ampleur mais beaucoup de
pancartes contre la réforme des
retraites dans les cortèges alors hasard
du calendrier ou pas c'est le jour qui a
choisi le gouvernement pour faire un
geste et accepter de concerter mais le
tout sous la menace on va essayer d'y
voir plus clair avec vous Mathieu
Lefebvre bonsoir et merci d'être là vous
êtes députés Renaissance le parti
présidentiel député du Val-de-Marne
bonsoir Aurélie trouvée ravi de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau député la
France insoumise de Seine-Saint-Denis
bonsoir Jean-Claude Mailly et merci
d'être là ancien secrétaire général de
Force Ouvrière et chroniqueurs à
l'hebdomadaire Frontier rare et puis
Christophe Barbier compte présente plus
évidemment éditorialiste BFM TV va nous
rejoindre dans quelques toutes petites
minutes
c'est lui le temps de nous planter le
décor comme chaque soir par la Bible
lakowski si j'ai bien compris tout de
suite
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
à toutes à tous d'ailleurs si j'ai bien
compris ce soir alors si j'ai bien
compris Myriam Emmanuel Macron est le
seul président de la République qui n'a
pas réussi à réformer le système d'air
retraite c'est le Figaro qui l'an
dernier se faisait un malin plaisir à
souligner l'échec de ce premier mandat
donc pour le nouveau mandat pas question
de plancher c'est décidé le président
Macron veut réformer les retraites mais
des mises en oeuvre de la réforme dès
l'été prochain donc ça permettra de
reculer l'âge du départ à la retraite à
64 ans en 2027 puis à 65 ans en 2031
alors attendez parce que la première
ministre elle se donne un petit peu plus
de temps si j'ai bien compris Stéphane
en ouvrant un nouveau cycle de
concertation ça veut dire que tout reste
ouvert non non ça c'est juste enfin
c'est pas vraiment des négociations
soyons net c'était juste pour rassurer
les trouillards de la majorité vous
voyez les barrons
du retour des gilets jaunes sur les
ronds-points mais je veux dire de toute
façon ça vraiment pas cher de discuter
on parle pas de négociation vous avez
noté c'est un cycle de concertation donc
ça fait un petit peu de cellules
psychologique pour accompagner les
syndicats et l'opposition pour les aider
à avaler la pilule parce que c'est
décidé je vous dis le président ne
reculera pas d'un pouce de dissoudre
l'Assemblée si sa réforme n'était pas
votée exactement hier soir dîner de la
majorité à l'Élysée il y a eu des fuites
évidemment et on apprend que le
président aurait tapé du point sur la
table il a dit attention si il y a on
vote une notion de censure à l'Assemblée
avec la déposition renverse le
gouvernement on va pas seulement changer
le Premier ministre là tout le monde
c'est l'assemblée qui sera dissoute donc
c'était un petit peu le retour de
Jupiter hier à l'Elysée et donc ce matin
le ministre du travail était un petit
peu embarrassé lui parce que forcément
des négociations ont les mènent pas à
coup de poing avec des coups de poing
sur la table donc il a essayé de ne pas
contredire le président disant oui bien
sûr qu'on pourrait faire une dissolution
mais sans prononcer le mot dissolution
très très à droite on écoute
si toutes les oppositions squalisées
pour adopter une notion de censure et
faire tomber le gouvernement et s'en
remettrai aux Français et les Français
trancheraient
pas grand monde dans les oppositions
vous le savez c'est un peu la cour de
récré si le président Macron dit c'est
moi le chef si je veux je dis sous
l'assemblée que répond l'opposition même
pas peur
que ça Marine Le Pen a fait un petit
tweet chiche et puis du côté les filles
bon Mathilde pas loin un peu poussé le
bouchon en disant on est prêt à vous
défaire mais je pense qu'en fait cette
tenace de dissolution elle concerne
surtout les républicains des fois qu'ils
auraient l'idée de se prendre vraiment
pour l'opposition et de voter la notion
de censure avec le RN ou avec la
nupaisse mais en même temps pourquoi les
républicains voteraient contre la
retraite à 135 ans puisque c'était une
proposition de Valérie Pécresse pendant
la campagne la campagne présidentielle
pour que le gouvernement et le président
recul il faudrait une énorme
mobilisation dans la rue ça a commencé
aujourd'hui la CGT avait prévu de
manifester il y a le 16 octobre une
nouvelle manifestation donc on a
toujours cette idée de 95 en tête où les
manifs avaient fait plier le
gouvernement mais il y a quand même 30
ans depuis aucune manif n'empêcher les
réformes à part Macron qui les a pas
faites si on considère que c'est pas le
covid
alors mettons que les manifestations est
posée pour l'empêcher mais il y a
peut-être une autre manière en tout cas
de mobiliser les Français ça c'est
l'idée de Fabien Roussel une idée donc
il avait déjà parlé au mois d'août et
donc il a reparlé ce matin on écoute
s'il veut que l'on revote et si les
palais jusque là moi je propose qu'il y
ait un référendum sur cette question des
projets projets contre projet il y aura
le projet de la droite et de Macron
puisqu'ils sont d'accord sur la
longement de la jauge des parents
retraite et il y aura le projet de la
gauche qui propose d'autres formes de
financement et la retraite à 60 ans et
on dit que c'est finançables et qu'il y
en a besoin et ben faisons débattre les
Français sur ces deux projets
il n'y a pas de quoi cette année vous
savez que le président n'écarte pas du
tout l'idée de faire un référendum sur
les retraites regardez c'est marqué dans
le journal ça fait partie des
possibilités qu'il envisage tout à fait
et puis je vais même vous dire il est
tout à fait prêt à faire des concessions
il est prêt à faire des concessions en
disant bon on va s'arrêter à 64 ans on
n'ira pas jusqu'à 65 ans tout ça il l'a
dit mais effectivement comme vous
l'aviez remarqué parce que vous êtes
très fine ou deux il a dit ça le 10
avril 15 jours avant le second tour de
la présidentielle c'était l'époque où il
préhardit une nouvelle réforme vous
voyez on passer en force pas du tout les
anciennes méthodes à coups de 49-3 donc
on se demande s'il n'y a pas un petit
retour de Jupiter au moment où on va
devoir discuter de la réforme des
retraites ce qu'il y a des bas merci
merci pour cet excellent papier comme
chaque soir Stéphane on va commencer par
la méthode on va essayer d'y voir un peu
plus clair avec vous Mathieu Lefebvre
est-ce qu'on est dans une forme de recul
tactique ou est-ce qu'on est dans un
véritable dialogue social où tout
resterait ouvert est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire ce soir que le gouvernement a
renoncé à passer en force ou pas je sais
pas ce que ça veut dire passer en force
en tout cas moi je sais que le
gouvernement est bon poursuivre il veut
poursuivre les concertations avec à la
fois les partenaires sociaux et
l'ensemble des forces politiques de ce
pays mais c'est important pour nous que
de pouvoir commencer à parler maintenant
de cette réforme elle-même il y a la
méthode et elle est très importante
elle-même et je crois que les Français
l'attendent d'accord mais c'est vous qui
avez créé un long suspense une attente
de plusieurs jours voir semaine sur
cette question de il y aura pas
d'amendement au projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale sur
le financement du système des retraites
monsieur le député l'objectif c'est
d'avoir un projet de loi dédié
l'objectif c'est d'avoir un projet de
loi dédié comme l'expliqué le ministre
du Travail avant Noël et de pouvoir
faire adopter cette loi avant la fin de
l'hiver en mars pour la mettre en œuvre
dès l'été 2023 parce qu'il y a pas une
minute à perdre pour préserver notre
système par répartition
que les générations concernées les
premières travailleront peut-être plus
longtemps 63 64 65 dès l'été prochain
absolument la référence sera mis en
oeuvre dès l'été prochain Aurélie Trouvé
avant de parler du fond de la réforme
sur la méthode
donc en fait c'est quoi pour vous c'est
un geste d'apaisement ou c'est rien du
tout la méthode du gouvernement reste la
même c'est-à-dire c'est la méthode
bulldozer donc on nous on nous dit bah
voilà ce sera fait avant la fin de
l'hiver on va faire des discussions
quand même histoire de tout enrober
voilà mais en l'occurrence ça va se
faire très très vite contre la vie
majoritaire des français puisque dans
les sondages c'est à peu près 70% des
Français qui sont contre le report de
l'âge légal enfin
des questions posées il y a des sondages
celui d'hier par exemple est là pour BFM
TV 55% pas d'accord pour travailler ça
fait quand même dans tous les sondages
une majorité de Français en l'occurrence
en 2020 nous avions réussi à leur
pousser moi à l'époque j'étais dans le
mouvement social j'étais responsable
d'attaque mais on l'avait repoussé dans
la rue on l'avait ça avait été repoussé
aussi dans l'hémicy qui avait eu toute
une bataille et je pense que ce sera
repoussé une nouvelle fois à raison pour
laquelle vous avez vous avez raison de
craindre que les Français se mobilisent
d'ailleurs je le dis nous avons cet
après-midi c'était le tour de chauffe je
vais vous dire alors
vous le reconnais tour de chauffe et
puis le 16 octobre moi j'appelle tout le
monde et là il y aura de nombreuses
forces politiques quasiment toute la
gauche et l'écologie seront là nous
aurons aussi beaucoup d'associations de
syndicats plein de personnalités qui
appellent à cette marche et nous
espérons bien que ce soit massif pour et
bien que ce soit peut-être vous répondez
rapidement fait circuler la parole
bulldozer il y a aussi la politique de
l'autruche qui consiste à ne pas voir
les difficultés et les problèmes à la
fois démographiques et financiers de
notre système de retraite si vous pensez
que tout va bien qu'on peut continuer à
financer indéfiniment nos retraites par
l'endettement il y a pas de difficulté
mais peut-être que c'est pas la vision
que nous avons je suis toujours réponds
pas de problème c'est pas
un facteurs alors vous vous avez
largement l'habitude de ces fameuses
concertation consultation tout va se
passer au ministère du Travail d'abord
concertation c'est pas une négociation
ça veut dire que c'est le gouvernement
qui décide d'infiner ça c'est sûr c'est
toujours le cas sur les la retraite sauf
sur les retraites complémentaires ça
c'est géré par les partenaires sociaux
mais la retraite ça relève d'une loi
donc à partir de là on négocie pas une
loi on donne son avis le gouvernement
tient compte ou ne tient pas compte
c'est autre chose mais une finesse c'est
non seulement le gouvernement mais le
Parlement qui est amené pourquoi il
lâche un petit peu de la sur le
calendrier il se donne un peu de temps
alors qu'on sait déjà que tous les
syndicats toutes les grandes centrales
sont contre
de l'âge légal ou l'allongement contre
tout sur le financement je pense qu'il y
a deux raisons il y a une raison
politique interne il y a dans la
majorité certains demandaient à ce que
s'il y a pas de passage en force via un
amendement au projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale je
pense à François Bayrou à la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale et deuxième
raison c'est quand même un peu compliqué
de dire je change de méthode je mets en
place un Conseil national de la
refondation mais en même temps je
discute pas donc il y avait une
contradiction donc là ça fait trois mois
comme dirait les enfants c'est moins
grave que si c'était pire quoi d'une
certaine manière bon après ça le fond du
dossier il est toujours là bonsoir
Christophe on a forcément besoin de
votre expertise politique
d'analyste observation concertée mais
sous la menace se donner un peu de temps
lâcher du leste mais menacé d'une
dissolution tout le monde repart en
campagne à quoi joue le président de la
République il essaye de reprendre le
monopole de l'autorité d'abord de
l'autorité sur son camp c'était l'enjeu
du dîner hier ou après toutes les
dissonances que Jean-Claude maillet ok
il fallait dire qu'elle était le cap et
le cap maintenant ou là 65 ans on a le
calendrier l'hiver l'été l'application
on a tout ça donc il y a ce qui est
négociable ou discutable il y a ce qui
n'est pas ensuite reprendre l'autorité
aussi sur ces oppositions certaines
d'entre elles en disant attention si
vous arrivez à faire voter par assez de
monde une motion de censure et renverser
le gouvernement c'est devant le peuple
que vous irez vous expliquer et voir sur
quel projet de gouvernement vous vous
pouvez avoir une majorité mais sur les
LR la pression est un peu différente les
républicains on leur dit attendez c'est
la réforme que vous projetiez dont vous
rêviez que vous auriez peut-être dû
faire quand Nicolas Sarkozy était
Président nous la faisons voter là donc
il y a une forme de pression sachant
qu'au moment où ce texte arrivera au
vote les républicains se seront dotés de
French date d'un nouveau président il
voudra sans doute être le meilleur des
opposants plutôt que de voter cette
réforme donc il y a une sorte de bras de
fer de poker de défis on a vraiment
l'impression d'une partie de poker
mentori il y a deux petites phrases qui
ont fuité de ce dîner de la majorité à
l'Elysée signée attribuer selon des
participants au chef de l'État je ne
veux pas d'acheter en ligne c'est une
motion censure est adoptée tout le monde
repart en campagne et puis un amendement
c'est beaucoup moins con je cite que de
faire des négociations des mégots dit-il
qui iront dans le mur Christophe Barbier
ça veut dire quoi très concrètement ça
veut dire que en gros si à Noël on
aboutit à rien avec des syndicats et
bien il peut y avoir un projet de loi
rectificatif sécurité sociale et on
passe en force 49-3 c'est même pas je
crois chercher à aboutir avec les
syndicats dans une négociation c'est pas
une négociation mais il a expliqué c'est
une loi donc il faut expliquer au
syndicat éventuellement compléter ce qui
n'est pas négociable et 65 ans par des
mesures pour éviter les effets pervers
on va parler pénibilité on va parler
carrière longue on va parler de la
retraite minimale 1100 euros au train où
va l'inflation est-ce que c'est
suffisant comme on l'index sur le coût
de la vie donc c'est ça qui pourra être
discuté et enrichi c'est toutes ces
propositions amendement de la société
civile et des syndicats amendement des
oppositions mais autour d'un noyau dur
qui n'est plus négociable qui n'est pas
mis en négociation 65 ans et un
calendrier alors derrière ça à travers
cette discussion il y a l'enjeu qui est
fondamental c'est en effet de s'adresser
à l'opinion publique l'opinion publique
a répondu dans les dernières réformes
par de la colère choléra en 2009 ça n'a
pas empêché la réforme Fillon de passer
colère en ça a compliqué la tâche du
gouvernement et après il y a eu le mur
de la covid et malgré l'adoption
première lecture ça c'est ça c'est
ensablé donc la colère sociale comment
on la désamorce avec une opinion qui ne
veut pas de ces réformes alors justement
on arrive à convaincre que les réalités
chiffrées démographiques doivent
s'imposer aux réalités rêvées des
Français c'est en effet travailler plus
personne n'a envie de partir à la
retraite alors justement on va venir au
fond de la réforme et vous le disez tout
va dépendre du climat social est-ce que
les Français sont prêts à bloquer le
pays sur les retraites ou pas premier
tour de chauffe vous le disiez Aurélie
trouver aujourd'hui à l'appel de la CGT
FSU solidaire mobilisation à la fois sur
le pouvoir d'achat mais aussi bien
évidemment sur les retraites elles
aiment mon Agava a pris la température
dans le cortège parisien reportage
dans le cortège parisien les
manifestants aimeraient croire au début
d'un automne de mobilisation sociale
pour nos salaires
et nos brigitte est infirmière avec ses
collègues elles sont venus dénoncer un
hôpital malade la situation des hôpitaux
après 30 ans d'austérité pas plus
personne ne veut travailler à l'hôpital
public donc on ferme des lits on a moi
c'est une situation inédite que je n'ai
jamais connue je suis infirmière depuis
1985 c'est qu'elle là on arrive on est
au bout du bout de ces réformes en
régressives David et Lorelei sont
enseignants qu'on a eu une première un
premier effet d'annonce de la part de du
président de la République concernant
une augmentation de 10% de nos salaires
à compter de janvier 2023 qui à l'heure
actuelle est repoussée pour septembre
2023 on a l'impression en tout cas qu'il
y a quelque chose qui se passe
et il y a des effectivement déjà des
choses qui se passent mais au niveau
local c'est pour ça que cette première
manifestation est importante parce qu'on
se retrouve tous on peut échanger une
mobilisation sociale qui pourrait être
dopée par l'hostilité contre la réforme
des retraites
Christelle bientôt 55 ans état de sème
elle travaille dans les écoles
maternelles de la capitale me dit toute
ma vie va falloir que je travaille
encore plus longtemps jusqu'à quel âge
vous voulez que je travaille auprès
d'enfants j'aimerais bien que le
Président nous écoute un petit peu voit
ce qui se passe vraiment sur le terrain
parce que je suis pas sûr dans les
hautes sphères ils savent vraiment ce
qu'on vit et c'est pas par gaieté de
coeur moi je perds plus de 60 euros j'ai
autre chose à faire que perdre 60 euros
à chaque fois je fais grève Olivier 42
ans techniciens chez Safran il s'est
déjà mobilisé contre la réforme en 2019
il fera de même en 2022 la dernière
réforme des retraites dans ma boîte on a
sorti cinq cartes cinq cartes de
manifestants qui montaient à Paris
combat j'ai fait gilet jaune gilet rouge
gilet noir mais nous on est prêt à se
mettre en grève le temps qu'il faudra de
toute manière on a rien sans rien les
syndicats vont se rencontrer dans les
prochains jours pour réfléchir à la
suite à donner aux mouvements
voilà on sent que voilà les syndicats
sont sont prêts à dégainer c'est très
clair et il y a des relais forcément au
sein au sein des salariés l'explosion
sociale Mathieu Lefebvre vous y croyez
ou pas parce qu'il y a un papier dans Le
Parisien qui dit que l'exécutif n'y
croient pas que les Français sont Tiger
vont circonscription qu'est-ce que vous
sentez je sais pas s'il faut y croire ou
pas y croire ce que je sais c'est que la
réforme elle se fera au Parlement elle
se fera pas elle se met bien sûr
évidemment ça compte évidemment
j'observe que les chiffres de la
mobilisation aujourd'hui sont avec tout
le respect que j'ai pour cette
mobilisation somme toute assez limité et
que la réforme elle se fera de toute
façon au Parlement mais ce qui est
important de dire et de dire à ces
personnes qui manifestent d'ores et déjà
contre cette réforme c'est que si nous
ne faisons rien si nous n'agissons pas
si nous nions le réel demande pourquoi
pas payer les pensions des personnes qui
partiront en retraite et cette réforme
elle est par ailleurs pas hémiplégique
on prévoit également d'augmenter le
minimum contributif c'est-à-dire la
retraite minimale à 1100 euros quand
vous dites payer les retraites des
retraités de leurs enfants notre système
est Inter générationnel vous nous dites
que l'argent économisé en travaillant
plus longtemps c'est sûr ira dans les
caisses de retraite parce que le
gouvernement lui-même laisse entendre
parfois qu'il servira à financer autre
chose à savoir le plan de relance dans
l'écologie à savoir la réduction des
déficits pour présenter une copie
budgétaire sérieuse à Bruxelles d'abord
vous évoquez le fait qu'il y a un sujet
budgétaire et je suis heureux que vous
le partagiez le Conseil d'orientation
des retraites le montre à l'horizon 2030
c'est 20 milliards d'euros de déficit
cette réforme elle va financer d'abord
les retraites existantes permettent de
faire en sorte que chacun puisse avoir
droit à l'utiliser une vie de travail à
la retraite à laquelle il a droit mais
aussi d'améliorer le système existant la
réforme la retraite minimale à 1100
euros l'amélioration des égalités
salariales entre les femmes et les
hommes la prise en compte de la
pénibilité des carrières longues donc
cette réforme elle n'est pas
hémiplégique comme le prétend de
certains aurai les trouver vous
reconnaissez que le sujet il est sur la
table depuis de longs mois voire
plusieurs années les Français ne
découvrent pas les paramètres de cette
réforme il y a un rapport du corps
Conseil d'orientation des Ret plus 12,5
milliards d'euros par an de déficit en
2027 20 milliards d'euros par an en 2030
d'abord vous prenez certains passages
sans voir les hypothèses d'abord ce
système le rapport du corps le montre
est excédentaire sur 2022 de plusieurs
milliards d'euros et ensuite à long
terme et à long terme il devient
déficitaire effectivement de peu
d'ailleurs
à long terme
et je vais vous dire pourquoi parce
qu'il y a deux hypothèses qui sont
prises en compte et nous l'avons bossé
avec tous nos économistes d'abord parce
qu'il est pris en compte toutes les
baisses de cotisation sociale c'est à
dire que ce déficit il est fabriqué par
le gouvernement en baissant toujours
plus les cotisations sociales notamment
sur les heures supplémentaires et
deuxièmement parce qu'il y a notamment
des hypothèses sur les fonctionnaires
sur une baisse à la fois relative des
revenus et du nombre de fonctionnaires
ce qui n'est pas acceptable ce que nous
disons nous c'est qu'au contraire on
peut même financer une retraite à 60 ans
et même le corps le disait en augmentant
un tout petit peu les cotisations
sociales c'est faisable et en faisant en
sorte que le taux d'emploi soit un peu
plus important notamment si on mettait
les femmes au même niveau d'emploi que
les hommes et bien nous pourrions aussi
avoir davantage de de cotisations et
donc financer ce système de retrait donc
il n'y a aucune fatalité Emmanuel Macron
dit ça va être douloureux il n'y a pas
de fatalité à souffrir davantage et
quand on croisea qui a fabriqué le
système des retraites qu'il a mis en
place dit les retraites ne doivent pas
être l'antichambre de la mort mais une
nouvelle étape de la vie voilà ce que
nous voulons et nous refusons le rouleau
compresseur ce bulldozerne et au libéral
est en train de de dérouler dans l'âme
ancien de Force Ouvrière qui fait non de
la tête un peu de maïs je rappelle que
le Ministre en charge à l'époque c'était
Alexandre Parodi c'était Ambroise CROIZE
avant et le premier qui a défendu et
proposer le nouveau système de sécurité
sociale c'était à la commission
consultative d'Algérie
et vous avez regardé évidemment le
rapport du corps est-ce qu'il y a
urgence comment vous lisez ce rapport à
réformer les retraites et donc à
travailler plus longtemps c'est
compliqué oui le corps travaille
correctement je n'ai pas ça en cause
mais c'est compliqué faut bien savoir
que le corps travaille d'abord jusqu'en
2027 sur les hypothèses faites par le
gouvernement et dans les hypothèses
faites par le gouvernement il y a un
taux de chômage à 5%. quand le corps
quasiment le retour en pleine emploi
quand il est peu probable quand le corps
après fait son sa consultation d'une
quinzaine d'économistes il considère lui
pour les années suivantes qu'on sera à
7%. donc il y a un problème de
raccordement entre les deux périodes et
ce problème de raccordement quand vous
voyez la courbe ça accentue le déficit
des retraites donc faut tout regarder
quoi je veux dire que dans le genre de
situation alors moi je dis pas qu'il
faut rien faire je prends un seul
exemple le taux de remplacement
c'est-à-dire le votre niveau de retraite
par rapport à votre dernier salaire pour
les futurs générations il va quand même
si on change rien il continue à baisser
donc ça c'est des éléments qu'il faut
prendre alors qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
faire selon vous est-ce qu'il faut mixer
l'allongement de durée de cotisation à
une mesure d'âge faire uniquement de la
réforme Touraine en allongeant la durée
de cotisation
le problème de de la France c'est qu'on
a joué sur les deux tableaux
historiquement on a à la fois allongé
plus que d'autres la durée de cotisation
moi je trouve que c'est un peu hypocrite
la durée de cotisation je le dis
clairement et on a moins augmenté l'âge
c'est vrai bon là les gens du privé ils
partent à quel âge le liquidation de
leur retraite aujourd'hui c'est 63 un
peu plus de 60 63 ans si on ne fait rien
quelqu'un qui est né en 73 qui aura
commencé à cotiser à 21 ans si la cotise
et partira 64 à taux plein donc il faut
il faut tout mettre sur la table
d'ailleurs ceux qui sont plus favorables
à un recul de l'âge de la retraite ce
sont les retraités
Christophe Barbier c'est intéressant
parce que ce raisonnement est-ce qu'il
est invisible parce qu'il est entré au
fond dans l'esprit des Français est-ce
que le gouvernement allait bon capteur
quand il se dit ça va passer il y aura
pas de levée de bouclier les Français
regardent ailleurs sur l'énergie sur
l'hiver compliqué sur l'Ukraine
l'histoire montre quand ça va mal quand
les Français sont anxieux ils se
révoltent pas ils sont nés dans le
guidon il faut en effet régler ses
problèmes d'énergie et donc c'est pas
dans ces périodes-là qu'on que la colère
s'exprime le plus c'est plutôt dans les
sorties de crise où on veut on veut ça
part du gâteau donc ça ça serait un
calcul un peu cynique de parier sur le
l'état d'esprit des Français déprimés
pour ne pas se révolter en revanche il
faut regarder pourquoi les Français
refusent de travailler plus longtemps
c'est parce que pour certains d'entre
eux on leur dit à 55 ans vous n'êtes
plus bon à rien donc ils disent attendez
je vais passer donc 10 ans au chômage
avant d'en fin pour être traités
non non il y a de l'épanouissement dans
le travail jusqu'à 65 ans et on fait en
sorte que même pour les travaux pénibles
les aménagements de carrière fassent que
ça soit supportable et que ça ne gâche
pas cette deuxième ou troisième vie qui
est la retraite les gens seraient
peut-être plus favorables et puis
deuxièmement ils se disent mais si je
pars à 65 ans qu'est-ce qui me reste
derrière comme pouvoir d'achat qu'est-ce
qu'il me reste à vivre quels sont mes
perspectives est-ce que je pourrais par
exemple continuer à avoir une vie
sociale en travaillant un peu comme
retraité des tâches utiles c'est tout ça
qu'il faut enrichir pour que les
Français se disent à un moment donné le
contrat il est complet c'est pas
seulement financier coûte de plus en
plus cher faut tous le souhaiter ça veut
dire qu'on vit plus longtemps si un jour
on vit tous 100 ans bah il y aura
beaucoup d'années de retraite à payer et
si on a des bonnes retraites tout ça
coûtera très cher après il y a comment
on finance et quand le gouvernement
c'est la même question mais je veux le
regarde de l'observateur explique que
bah oui il faut trouver de l'argent et
pas forcément pour les retraites il l'a
dit ça peut financer ou les déficits ou
des investissements est-ce que ça ça
passe dans l'opinion ou pas c'est une
erreur c'est une erreur je pense parce
que les gens aiment bien que ça soit
fléchés comme on dit si vous faites une
taxe qui s'appelle la vignette
automobile pour financer à une besoin
sociale et puis que ça s'installe dans
la durée parce que ça finance d'autres
choses ce n'est pas un contrat honnête
alors attention il y a des parenté il
s'agit pas de de prendre des cotisations
retraite pour construire des stades pour
la Coupe du monde de rugby il s'agit de
regarder si du côté de la dépendance
d'autres aspects de la santé il n'y a
pas des ponts communs oui mais alors
dans ce cas là repensions complètement
l'architecture de notre solidarité
nationale pour expliquer pourquoi il y a
des vases communicants entre ce qui est
déficitaire et ce qui est et ça ça
nécessite un contrat politique avec le
peuple un peu plus large alors faire
énormément de pédagogie
vous avez le sentiment que le
gouvernement est même le président a été
clair sur les retrait depuis le début on
est passé 65 ans pendant la campagne à
différents paramètres possibles la durée
de cotisation une mesure d'âge qui
pourrait être 63 aujourd'hui on revient
sur une mesure d'âge vous trouvez ça
lisible on peut pas dire que d'un côté
tout est ficelé tout vient d'en haut et
de l'autre que le Président il est pas
clair c'est pas possible moi je crois
que le Président il a été extrêmement
clair il a eu beaucoup de courage
pendant la campagne présidentielle de se
prononcer pour le report de l'âge légal
monsieur Mailly l'a dit à juste titre la
seule augmentation de la durée de
cotisation elle est un petit peu
hypocrite parce qu'elle contribue à ce
que les gens ne puissent pas partir
sans décote aujourd'hui mais le
Président il est extrêmement clair et
par ailleurs sa majorité l'est tout
autant puisqu'on est tous
ne se fera pas sans une mesure d'achat
je ne connais pas quel âge en tout cas
il y a deux choses c'est sur la table
premièrement et deuxièmement ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que si on fait
uniquement de l'accélération de
cotisation ça suffit pas à résoudre le
problème financier le corps le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites à la montrer
ah bah c'est dans son rapport
sociaux sièges au Conseil d'orientation
des retraites vous vous déformez les
résultats du rapport du corps
de la mort et sur la phrase d'ambroscope
parce qu'elle est importante aujourd'hui
il faut quand même se rendre compte que
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé elle a
64 ans donc faire partir les les gens au
moins 65 ans parce qu'en réalité ça va
être plus tard avec toute le système
d'annuité et bien c'est les faire partir
en moyenne après après cet âge là
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui pour les gens
les gens les plus pauvres pour les 10%
les gens les plus pauvres il y a à 62
ans il y a déjà 25% des gens qui sont
décédés c'est ça qu'il faut voir mais la
pensée
à tout plein je peux vous dire que dans
dans Seine-Saint-Denis beaucoup de par
exemple de dames viennent me voir de 70
ans me disent voilà je gagne 600 700 €.
nous à la nups nous demandons est-ce
qu'il y a un minimum vieillesse à 1100 €
c'est ça que nous demandons et nous
pouvons le financer parce que nous
l'avons travaillé avec tout un bocage
blackroéconomique et budgétaire qui le
donne
sur le grand absent c'est Laurent Berger
la CFDT on a du mal à suivre on a
l'impression qu'ils sont contre toute la
réforme mais pas forcément il y en a un
qui est prêt on découvre c'est lui on va
l'écouter c'est Philippe Martinez et
puis on revient sur la CFDT juste après
si on vous invite Delphine orvillers
c'est pour nous aider à répondre à une
question facile
dans les cortèges s'il vous plaît de la
CGT pardonnez-nous
on va l'écouter
allez quelques secondes encore
allez on l'écoute
il dit qu'il a changé mais il veut il
veut imposer sa loi il veut imposer son
opinion et face à une majorité de
Français qui dit qui disent on ne veut
pas l'allongement de leur retraite face
à uneanimité des syndicats qui disent il
ne faut pas reculer l'âge de la retraite
soit il a changé soit il continue et il
cherche le rapport de force il va le
trouver
Laurent Berger il faut expliquer parce
qu'il y a des élections professionnelles
qui arrivent de la CFDT il pense quoi
parce qu'on a l'impression que sa base
est très clairement contre cette réforme
totalement sur le fond est-ce que c'est
jouable d'embarquer la CFDT dans cette
réforme ou pas que ce soit lié à des
élections professionnelles tout
simplement la CFDT a tenu son congrès il
y a quelques mois et quand vous êtes
secrétaire général d'une confédération
c'est pas vos positions personnelles que
vous défendez quelle qu'elle soit vous
avez des mandats et des votes issus de
position de prise dans un congrès et le
congrès de la CFDT a clairement dit
qu'il était opposé à recul de l'âge et
opposé à une augmentation de la durée
donc il respecte respecte le mandat ça
c'est le premier point et le deuxième
point quand j'ai entendu Laurent Berger
expliqué qui est demandé à être loyal ça
veut dire que je pense qu'il considère
que dans ces rapports avec le
gouvernement il y a un manque de loyauté
et ça il y a rien de pire si votre
interlocuteur vous pensez qu'il est pas
loyal ben ça veut dire que comme on le
comprend il y a un front syndical très
clair toutes les syndicats pourraient se
retirer de toutes les concertations
sociales de ce nouveau mandat d'Emmanuel
Macron parce qu'elle assurance chômage
il y a France travail il y a
l'apprentissage il y a énormément de
choses derrière connaître un peu le
président puis maintenant mais quand
j'étais en fonction il y a une chose
sur laquelle c'est pas son truc quoi
c'est le dialogue social il considère il
a toujours considéré que c'était une
perte de temps voilà que c'était un
frein pour des réformes qu'il fallait
aller vite etc bon donc ça c'est un
élément clé et là je ne sais pas les
syndicats se retrouvent je le 3 octobre
je crois tous ensemble je sais pas ce
qu'ils vont ce qu'ils vont décider mais
il y a effectivement uneanimité
aujourd'hui sur la question d'âge et la
question de durée ça c'était évident
mais
intermédiaires se présidente pardon
juste un mot Christophe a raison il faut
pas enfin moi je dis il faut pas mettre
la charrue avant les bœufs si on
commence à discuter de ce dossier en
parlant emploi des seniors modification
de l'organisation du travail les tout ce
qui a tout ce que la crise sanitaire a
créé comme changement dans le travail il
faut commencer à travailler là-dessus et
on parle des retraites aussi
que ça sert à rien le dialogue social
c'est qu'il trouve que trop souvent ça
se termine par des syndicats qui
refusent de signer donc on a perdu du
temps et notamment la CGT qui ne signe
jamais mais un président doit quand même
être dans ce dialogue et en effet
respecter les corps intermédiaires mais
il y a pas que les syndicats dans les
corps intermédiaires il y a aussi les
oppositions pour la CFDT il y a aussi le
deuil qu'elle doit faire de cette
retraite à point qui est pendant tant
d'années qui a failli passer ça s'est
joué à quelques semaines et qui ne
reviendra pas dans le débat et ça
c'était pensé un total autre système
c'était une véritable révolution
ce pari de la rue contre le président
est-ce que la russe sera comment 95
comment 2019 assez forte pour faire
perdre du temps voir faire reculer ou
est-ce que les Français résignés ou
convaincus ou un mélange des deux on
finir par dire bon allez on savait qu'on
y passerait mais l'histoire dure
longtemps 65 ans en ce moment parce que
démographiquement financièrement
économiquement c'est difficile mais si
ça se trouve dans 20 ans on pourra dire
attendez nous pouvons redescendre à 62
60 parce que nous avons de la croissance
une démographie favorable
puis on est remonté depuis 1980 merci
beaucoup on va suivre évidemment ce
dossier extrêmement sensible de prêt ici
même à l'Assemblée nationale mais aussi
le 16 octobre dans la rue merci d'avoir
participé à ce débat sur LCP on va à
présent accueillir notre grand témoin
les femmes rabbins écrivains et bien
plus encore en témoigne son dernier
livre un texte court très drôle mordant
contre tous les obsédés de l'identité il
n'y a pas de Hajar chez Grasset
monologue ou elle l'imagine un fils à
Émile Hajar le fils d'une falsification
littéraire celle de l'écrivain Romain
Gary s'est vertigineux Delphine
orvillers nous rejoint tout de suite
après l'invitation de Clément Méric avec
ce soir Charlotte c'est bien à l'image
si on vous invite Delphine orvillers
c'est pour nous aider à répondre à une
question pas si simple qui suis-je tenez
vous-même qui êtes-vous Delphine
orphelin si on se penche sur votre CV la
réponse la plus immédiate est femme
rabbin sauf que vous avez aussi été
mannequin et journaliste après le bac
vous partez en Israël c'est là que vous
faites du mannequinat pour financer vos
études de médecine vos bifurkez ensuite
vers le journalisme et devenez reporter
à France Télé le projet de loi
présentait aujourd'hui par le ministre
de la Santé Bernard Kouchner va dans le
sens de secours mais en 2003 nouveau
virage vous quittez la France pour vous
inscrire dans une école rabinique à New
York 5 ans plus tard vous devenez la
troisième femme rabbin à exercer en
France de ce cheminement vous tirez une
leçon on n'a jamais fini de dire ce
qu'on pourrait être c'est à dire que il
existe dans la vie toujours une
possibilité de devenir autre chose et
que il y a rien de pire que de
s'imaginer qu'on est arrivé
il n'y a donc pas une mais plusieurs
Delphine orvillers ne pas se laisser
renfermer dans une seule identité c'est
justement le thème de votre dernier
livre il n'y a pas de Hajar texte jouer
actuellement au Théâtre des plateaux
sauvages dans ce monologue vous prêtez
votre plume au fils imaginaire des
milles ajars pseudo de Romain Gary qui
fut lui-même écrivain mais aussi
aviateur diplomate et réalisateur il y a
beaucoup de gens qui pensent qu'on est
ce que nos naissances ont fait de nous
nos ethnies nos religions nos parents
nos filiation mais moi je voilà je
suggère dans ce texte que on n'est pas
juste les enfants de nos parents ou de
nos familles on est bien souvent en tout
cas moi je me reconnais là dedans on est
les enfants des livres qu'on a lu et ça
m'a rejet dit disait que de façon très
juste que la simplification nos
identités nous amène à voir très vite en
l'autre un ennemi au fil des pages de ce
livre si différents des autres une
question nous vient Delphine nordviller
à l'image de Romain Gary ne seriez-vous
pas une fois de plus en train de vous
réinventer
[Musique]
bonsoir Delphine nordviller bonsoir et
merci beaucoup d'être là alors il n'y a
pas de Hajar monologue contre l'identité
chez graphet c'est une autre Delphine
orchelor qu'on découvre qu'on rencontre
un peu différent je dirais très très
drôle mordant parfois même un Solente
est-ce que c'est aussi ça ce livre
est-ce qu'à l'image de Romain Gary de
son œuvre et de toute sa vie vous aviez
envie de vous réinventer oui c'est vrai
que je j'aime l'idée qu'on n'a jamais
fini de dire qui on est je me rends
compte dans le sujet que vous avez
présenté que je je le dis depuis un
moment mais ce livre me permet de le
dire un peu plus fortement de faire un
pas de côté et puis c'était important
pour moi de l'écrire après vivre avec
nos morts qui était mon livre précédent
qui était sur un sujet très blue pesant
le deuil qui menaçait un peu pour moi de
m'enfermer dans un certain rôle rabbini
d'accompagnement des familles
endeuillées et j'avais besoin de
reprendre un peu d'oxygène d'écrire un
peu autrement d'avoir recours aussi à la
fiction à l'exagération parce que le
personnage de ce livre est un peu moins
mais quand même pas complètement
heureusement il est beaucoup plus
exubérant et énervé et en colère que je
ne beaucoup plus que je ne le suis alors
c'est Abraham Hajar on va en parler
longuement qui est interprété par
Johanna lisard donc une femme une
comédienne c'est sur la scène du Théâtre
des plateaux sauvages alors jusqu'au 7
octobre et ce sera ensuite au Théâtre du
Rond-Point c'est bien ça ça va à
Villejuif à Suresnes dans bien des
théâtres et ce sera au Théâtre du
Rond-Point en décembre avant de
commencer une tournée alors quelle
histoire quelle histoire de cette fille
vous traite Romain Gary la plus grande
supercherie littéraire écrivez-vous du
20e siècle Gary le seul écrivain à avoir
reçu deux prix Goncourt l'un pour les
Racines du ciel sous son nom romain Gary
l'autre pour la vie devant soi sous son
pseudonyme et Émile Ajar d'abord
racontez-nous ce lien intime et
invisible que vous avez avec lui depuis
l'enfance quasiment depuis votre
naissance oui je dis souvent que Gary
est pour moi comme un ebooks moi en
hébreu qui signifie comme un fant ou
quelqu'un qui vous hante j'ai
l'impression que ces livres m'ont
accompagné je me vois encore adolescente
lire la promesse de l'aube voilà étant
d'autres livres la vie devant soi la
jarre tous ces livres qui m'ont
construit d'une certaine manière et
c'est vrai que je me suis sentie
toujours lié d'une certaine manière à la
tentative de Gary Gary c'est vraiment
quelqu'un par excellence qui a voulu se
réinventer et dire qu'il avait jamais
fini de dire qu'il était il s'est
construit 1000 vies j'ai souvent le
sentiment que Gary incarne pour moi la
figure du survivant dans tous les sens
du terme il a survécu à deux guerres
mondiales et la survécu à la Shoah qui a
décimé sa famille il a survécu au combat
d'aviateur de la deuxième guerre
mondiale mais il s'est aussi installé
comme un survivant en deux mots c'est à
dire qu'il a voulu au dessus de la vie
sur et puis il a tenté toute sa vie
d'avoir une vie plus grande que la vie
c'est à dire de se dire qu'il pourrait
avoir mille vie à l'intérieur d'une
existence et je trouve qu'il y a pas de
plus beau défi que ça c'est pas facile à
faire c'est une étrange promesse un peu
dangereuse d'ailleurs me semble-t-il
mais souvent je me suis sentie en tout
cas un peu
héritière de ça aussi parce que j'ai
moi-même dans mon histoire dans
l'histoire de ma famille des histoires
de survivance de survie et que je me
suis souvent demandé en changeant de
chemin en changeant de route en
changeant de carrière en changeant de
pays de quelle manière il m'était donné
de recommencer cette scène que vous
racontez c'est dans la préface c'est pas
dans le monologue ou ce jour de du 2
décembre 1980 Gary mais fait un séjour
cette scène vous toquait à sa porte bon
lui raconter un conte d'Anne ludique
est-ce que vous vous l'avez vraiment
imaginé souvent personnellement c'est un
peu dans la préface bien sûr il y a la
presque un fantasme un peu de
toute-puissance parce que d'imaginer que
j'aurais pu intervenir en 1980 un deux
décembre j'avais j'étais toute petite
toute petite à l'époque mais c'est vrai
que parfois je me suis demandé qu'est-ce
qui aurait pu se passer si on s'était
rencontré est-ce que ça voilà peut-être
changé ce moment déterminant en fait
bien entendu c'est la question n'est pas
de savoir pourquoi Gary s'est suicidé et
si on aurait pu interrompre suicide mais
en tout cas j'imagine une conversation
que finalement j'ai avec lui d'une
certaine manière de façon posthume les
gens qui ont compté pour vous que ce
soit des modèles des écrivains des
livres des hommes politiques parfois des
sources d'inspiration les héros de nos
vies leur particularité c'est que ils
ont une conversation avec vous parfois
même lorsqu'ils ne sont plus là quelque
chose qui peut se poursuivre dans le
dialogue que vous pourrez avoir avec eux
donc nous sommes autant que nos origines
nos familles nos héritages nous sommes
aussi les enfants des livres que nous
avons eu voilà le personnage dans le
livre dit qu'on est tous des créatures
littéralement d'une procréation
littéralement assistée en fait c'est
vrai moi je crois en tout cas moi je
perçois très bien dans ma vie comment
les livres m'ont construit ce que je
leur dois ce que je dois ma bibliothèque
à celle de mes parents mes
grands-parents aux histoires qu'on nous
a raconté alors je suis le fils je suis
le fils de la falsification légendaire
je suis l'enfant de l'entourloupe
littéraire majeur du 20e siècle je suis
le fils d'Émile à jars
comment ça vous est venu cette idée
franchement c'est génial d'inventer un
fils fictif à un personnage qui n'a pas
existé mais la jarre oui c'est une façon
de dire que cet enfant-là tout
particulièrement et l'enfant d'une
fiction comme on les finalement tous et
c'est aussi une façon de faire un pied
de nez pour moi à toutes ces obsessions
identitaires du moment tous ces gens qui
sont persuadés d'être qui sont parce
qu'ils sont nés quelque part qui sont
ils ont une identité bien installées
sédentarisée bien réel voilà inscrit
dans le réel moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui
peut-être plus que jamais on a besoin de
réhabiliter la fiction qui agrandit la
réalité qui nous permet d'avoir encore
une fois j'avais fini de dire qui on est
c'est-à-dire de refuser des assignations
identitaires qui une fois pour vous
enferme quelque part finalement depuis
des années on n'arrête pas d'être
entouré de ces discours qui reste dans
tellement fort l'idée d'ailleurs assez
fictive qu'il existerait une pureté des
origines pourquoi vous l'avez appelé
Abraham je l'ai appelé Abraham parce que
c'est là encore un peu un clin d'oeil à
l'humour d'une histoire finalement assez
méconnue Abraham c'est le père de tous
les croyants en tout cas dans les trois
monothéistes on s'est choisi dans les
trois monothéistes pour figure
paternelle un homme Abraham qui a envoyé
bouler le sien je sais pas si tout le
monde connaît cette histoire biblique
mais Abraham un jour dans la Bible
reçoit un appel ou Dieu lui dit quitte
la maison de ton père et je trouve ça à
la fois fascinant et en même temps plein
d'humour cette idée que les croyants se
choisissent pour père quelqu'un qui a
quitté la maison de son et en hébreu il
faut donner le nom du père oui on en a
en hébreu en plus il y a un élément
le fils d'un taré en fait littéralement
le père en hébreu s'appelle terreur mais
dans toutes les bips vous pouvez
vérifier en français le père d'Abraham
s'appelle Taris qui fait
programme un fils de taré et des fils
d'Abraham des petits-fils de taré alors
bien sûr c'est un peu un Solange que je
dis là mais c'est volontairement j'ai
voulu titiller le texte et la tradition
parce que je crois que le texte nous y
invite souvent on dit ces dernières
années qu'on peut plus rien de tout qui
a des sujets sur lesquels on peut plus
plaisanter et surtout pas les croyances
et moi dans ce livre j'ai voulu montrer
que si au contraire nos croyances elles
sont là pour être un peu questionnés
interrogés qu'il faut parfois leur faire
un peu violence justement pour qu'elle
reste suffisamment impertinente pour
être pertinente je voudrais vous montrer
cette archive Delphine nordviller de
Romain Gary sans doute vous la
connaissez déjà parce que avant
d'inventer Hajar Gary avait déjà utilisé
un pseudo Satan Bogat pour écrire les
têtes de Stéphanie il avait été
d'ailleurs vite démasqué il explique
pourquoi il est tout fait dans son image
d'écrivain établi et qu'il avait besoin
de se libérer de ça célébrité écoutez
j'essayais de me faire passer sous un
pseudony parce que très franchement je
crois que c'est le cas de tout le monde
il y a un moment où chacun doit servir à
avis de changer de peau de redevenir un
débutant de repartir dans une nouvelle
direction et de retrouver une certaine
virginité
et j'adore aussi le fait que quand Gary
écrivait sous le nom d'agent il y a
beaucoup de critiques qui disaient à jar
ça c'est un grand écrivain c'est quand
même beaucoup mieux que ce Garry un peu
médiocre et je pense qu'il y a un
fantasme pour tous les écrivains d'une
certaine manière ceux qui ont de
l'humour en tout cas t'imaginer qu'on
puisse écrire un livre sous un pseudo et
que quelqu'un dise c'est quand même
vachement mieux que cet autre là c'est
jubilatoire on l'imagine il n'y a pas de
hasard non plus vous de Hajar Gary écrit
en hébreu signifie mon étranger ou
l'étranger en moi oui alors je sais pas
s'il le savait s'il y avait pensé je
pense pas parce que c'est pour d'autres
raisons à mon avis qu'il avait choisi ce
nom de de Gary qui a quelque chose à
voir avec le feu et la braise
en russe je crois mais en hébreu c'est
vrai que le nom de Gary signifie
l'étrangeté en moi l'étranger en moi ou
mon étranger ce qui lui va bien en fait
de la même manière que Hajar le nom
qu'il se choisit et très très proche
d'un mot en hébreu à
qui veut dire l'autre l'altérité il
s'est amusant que tous les pseudos que
ce choisi en hébreu sans doute par
hasard Gary ont quelque chose à voir
avec une conscience d'altérité avec le
fait qu'il y a en nous de l'étranger et
de l'étrange T qui nous permet de jamais
complètement authentiquement
intégralement nous-mêmes alors c'est un
livre très sincère très tendre
extrêmement drôle aussi mais c'est aussi
un livre politique comment on fait très
concrètement dans la vie de tous les
jours pour accueillir ces identités
multiples alors de ces obsessions
identitaires alors où les jeunes
générations se déchirent avec leurs
aînés à leur ont on est renvoyé
systématiquement qu'elle soit
fondamentalisme qui nous ramène à nos
héritages à nos familles à nos
communautés je crois qu'il s'agit
toujours de complexifier le débat et de
refuser tout ce qui est monolithique
dans nos existences je relisais
récemment un livre qui moi m'a beaucoup
marqué un livre qui n'est pas de Gary
mais de Amos Oz qui a écrit un livre
magnifique qui s'appelle comment guérir
un fanatique et ce livre je pense que
tout le monde devrait lire aujourd'hui
parce qu'on est entouré de beaucoup de
fanatismes qui sont pas toujours des
fanatismes religieux d'ailleurs mais des
fanatisent de tout ordre et un mousse os
dit que le propre des fanatique c'est
que ce sont des gens qui ne savent
compter que jusque un et je trouve qu'il
y a rien de pire dans l'existence que ne
comptait que jusqu'à 1 c'est-à-dire de
croire qu'il y a une vérité un livre une
interprétation une façon de voir le
monde une façon de se définir
aujourd'hui on a besoin plus que jamais
de milfeuilles de complexité de se
raconter comme étant ceci trois petits
points cela etc et ce combat il n'est
pas perdu d'avance
on peut le gagner à condition vous avez
le vous parler il y a un instant des
conflit première générationnel pour
résoudre un conflit acheteur
générationnel il faut pas nier qu'on
critique parfois des générations passées
mais il faut être capable de reconnaître
la dette c'est-à-dire de savoir tout ce
qu'on doit au monde de sa naissance
qu'on peut critiquer mais ce qu'on lui
doit également voilà
hériter transmettre autre chose par
forcement de ce qu'on a reçu merci
infiniment vous restez avec moi Delphine
orwiller il n'y a pas de Hajar autant
vous dire que voilà il faut aller le
lire très très vite c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos affranchis pour leur
parti pris ce soir un nouveau visage le
philosophe Pierre-Henri tavoyau qui va
plaider vous allez le voir pour le
retour du cumul des mandats les séistes
Chloé ridelles revient sur un sujet qui
peut vous intéresser
Delphine orvillers la poussée de fièvre
identitaire en Europe et puis l’œil sur
le numérique de Delphine Sabatier ce
soir des douaniers américains qui
siphonnent les smartphones des voyageurs
nous affranchi les voici bonsoir à vous
trois ravi de vous retrouver d'abord
bonsoir Pierre-Henri ravi de vous dire
dans cette émission philosophe président
du Conseil du collège de philosophie
vous allez nous aider régulièrement dans
cette émission à mieux comprendre la
crise démocratique à travers toute une
série de débats vous vouliez revenir ce
soir sur la règle du nom cumul des
mandats il y a eu un débat qui est passé
un peu inaperçu la semaine dernière au
sein du groupe parlementaire Renaissance
sur le fait de revenir sur la
possibilité de revenir sur le
l'interdiction du cumul des mandats vous
le savez depuis 2014 il y a cette loi
qui dit grosso modo il y a pas de
députés il y a plus de députés mais il y
a plus de scène internet il faut rendre
impossible le fait de cumuler un mandat
exécutif local et un mandat national
donc cette loi moi personnellement je
trouve vraiment dommageable je la
retrouve dommageable c'est le prototype
d'une loi un peu démagogique qui sous
les apparences du progressisme cachent
vraiment des effets pervers néfastes et
beaucoup aussi et sur laquelle il est
extrêmement difficile de revenir à mon
sens les Français sont très très
favorables au nom cubiles s'écrase dans
73%
[Musique]
locales c'est quelque chose qui est un
trésor pourquoi son privé deuxièmement
il y a une perte de contact ça accentue
le clivage entre Paris et la province ça
crée une sorte de distance et les
Français aussi à 70% disent on veut des
élus qui soient plus proche de nous puis
un déficit démocratique soyons clairs on
n'arrête pas de forcer le choix des
citoyens leur disant faute voter pour
plus de représentation plus de diversité
etc les citoyens sont peuvent voter en
connaissance de cause on n'est pas
obligé de leur forcer le choix et puis
il y a quand même aussi un problème à
l'égard du Kratos du pouvoir d'emos et
Kratos parce que d'une certaine façon ce
type de loi c'est les élus admettent que
d'une certaine façon les citoyens ont
des raisons de se méfier des élus
arrondi disait
nul n'obéit à qui ne se croit à son
droit de commander j'ajouterai pourquoi
voter pour des gens qui vous disent et
bien le pouvoir corrompt merci beaucoup
merci pour ce premier parti pris
de réagir à cette question du cumul ou
d'une mais vous vous démultipliez
d'ailleurs on peut vous le reprocher au
revoir mais est-ce que ça vous écoute en
parler je me disais que moi j'ai
l'impression bien sûr dans un domaine
très très différent de cumuler des
mandats de
rester au contact des autres parce que
c'est ça cette question j'ai
l'impression effectivement au contraire
que chacune de mes expériences de mes
engagements nourris l'autre que une
fonction pastorale ou une fonction
d'enseignement parfois mon expérience
même de mère enfin me accent grave re je
fais que je j'ai le sentiment que voilà
je
tout toutes ces fonctions se nourrissent
et finalement se faire stylise enfin
c'est certain d'autres domaines Chloé
Ridel merci d'être avec nous et pour
cette nouvelle saison alors vous vouliez
revenir ce soir sur la victoire de
Georgia Meloni et plus largement sur
cette poussée identitaire des droites
conservatrices en Europe oui c'est vrai
parce que depuis dimanche soir on parle
beaucoup de la victoire du néo-fasciste
en Italie mais c'est en réalité une
vague ces droits d'identitaires qui
montent en Europe depuis les années 2010
et à travers laquelle on découvre que
les droits d'identitaires sont capables
de parler d'une seule voix au cœur de
cette offensive je veux souligner qu'il
y a un récit qui met en avant la
civilisation européenne décrite par e
comme étant blanche et chrétienne et un
récit qui répète adnosé âme que cette
civilisation serait menacée par
l'immigration et ce qu'ils appellent la
propagande LGBT et ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que la passion pour
l'identité qui anime les droites
d'identitaires n'est plus seulement
concentré sur la nation ce qui leur
faisait promettre de quitter l'Union
européenne mais aussi désormais sur la
civilisation dont l'échelle était
européenne est d'ailleurs Georgia Meloni
n'a cessé de répéter pendant sa campagne
en Italie non au bureaucrate de
Bruxelles mais oui à notre civilisation
et pour protéger cette civilisation
européenne il s'agirait pour Victor
urban pour Georgia Meloni en Italie ou
encore pour Éric Zemmour en France de
transformer l'Union européenne en une
sorte d'autorité garante de l'identité
culturelle et religieuse du continent
qui passerait par quelle mesure alors et
bien au programme il y aurait
l'immigration zéro des murs aux
frontières financées par le budget
européen pourtant très réduit c'est
d'ailleurs ce que demandait la Pologne
il y a un an quand elle subissait un
chantage migratoire de la part de la
Biélorussie ce sera aussi la restriction
du droit à l'avortement la
stigmatisation des minorités sexuelles
et religieuse aussi bien pour revenir à
la question qui nous occupe c'est-à-dire
qu'est-ce qui va nous arriver à travers
cette montée des droites identitaires en
Europe ça n'est pas le risque n'est pas
une dislocation de l'Union européenne ou
encore une réconciliation avec le régime
de Vladimir Poutine le plus grand risque
est ailleurs et prendrait la forme d'un
détournement des valeurs de l'Europe
mais aussi de ses priorités c'est à dire
que les droites identitaires risquent de
nous barricader derrière des murs et de
nous faire rater le train de l'histoire
à un moment où on a besoin de faire du
conflit ukrainien et de des changements
qu'il commande pour l'Europe une
priorité ils vont nous recentrer sur
leur thème de prédilection l'immigration
la lutte contre la propagande LGBT ou le
droit à l'avortement alors que nous
traversons une crise de l'énergie du
pouvoir d'achat de l'emploi avec la
guerre ferrages alors Chloé Ridel que
faire pour contrer ce vent mauvais comme
vous l'appelez c'est toute la question
et je pense ce que toute la tâche des
forces politiques progressistes pour les
années qui viennent nous avons perdu
beaucoup de combat dans la bataille
culturelle et la reconquête des esprits
prendra du temps en attendant je crois
qu'il ne faut rien céder sur nos
principes et s'attacher à faire de
l'Europe une puissance qui protège et
émancipe plutôt qu'une qui libéralise et
fragilise les démocraties par le règne
du tout marché mais il faut aussi ne pas
laisser aux droits d'identités le
monopole de définir ce que la
civilisation européenne qui n'est ni une
religion et encore moins une race une
civilisation se définit comme une
manière de vivre en général et ce sont
nos institutions démocratiques nos
libertés nos systèmes de redistribution
sociale de régulation écologique et de
cette manière de vivre il faut tirer le
meilleur et le revendiquer contre ceux
qu'il affaiblissent au prétexte de la
défendre voilà déjà quelques pistes
elle vous fait peur cette cette vague
identitaire
ultra conservatrice vous écoutant j'ai
l'impression que on connaît déjà
tellement le déroulé ce que vous énoncez
comme des mesures possibles à l'avenir
elles sont déjà tellement pré-écrites on
sait que cette obsession identitaire
elle rime toujours toujours avec
obsession de la pureté et peur de la
contamination que cette contamination
porte le nom de l'étranger ou de la
femme ou de l'homosexuel on a
l'impression que c'est prêt écrit qu'on
connaît le scénario et qu'on le voit à
nouveau se dérouler terriblement devant
nos yeux
on verra on verra ce que ça donnera dans
les dans les prochains mois Delphine
Sabatier on va parler d'un tout autre
sujet avec vous c'est votre œil sur le
numérique avec une information ce soir à
peine croyable les douaniers américains
siphonnent les mobiles des voyageurs et
donc ça se passe aux États-Unis mais en
fait ça nous concerne tous surtout si là
vous partez en voyage là-bas il faut
quand même bien vous accrocher parce que
l'ensemble des données contenues dans
nos mobiles nos PC portables nos
tablettes un tout y passe
potentiellement peut-être récupérer par
un douanier américain c'est le
Washington Post donc qui a révélé cette
affaire et on parle quand même là de
plus de 10000 appareils qui auraient été
comme ça siphonné chaque année par les
douaniers américains et ça peut être le
téléphone de n'importe qui et c'est ça
qui fait un peu peur Myriam c'est que ce
qu'on apprend dans les déclarations
c'est qu'en fait il y a pas besoin
d'être suspecté d'être l'auteur d'un
crime une simple suspicion raisonnable
ils appellent ça en fait de la part de
l'inspecteur douanier peut justifier la
copie donc de tout ce que contiennent
vos appareils mobiles quand vous êtes en
voyage et il y a aucun regard du juge
bien évidemment là-dessus donc je sais
pas si vous voyez le tableau mais enfin
un smartphone c'est quand même à peu
près l'ensemble de notre vie privée et
pour une entreprise un employé qui va se
déplacer son pc portable c'est quand
même un paquet de secret d'affaires à
l'intérieur et alors ils ont font quoi
toutes ces données alors grande question
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui nous a permis
d'être au courant de cette pratique
puisque le Congrès américain s'interroge
sur tout ce qui est fait de cette masse
de d'informations qui en plus est quand
même conservé pendant 15 ans et nous on
est protégé nous les Européens et nous
on est logé à la même enseigne que tout
le monde alors à part refuser au
douaniers l'accès parce qu'il faut quand
même déverrouiller finalement son
appareil c'est la seule chose qu'on peut
envisager mais enfin je pense que là ça
quand même ça gage complètement le
séjour et donc à part nous alerter et ce
scandaliser qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
je pense que c'est déjà important d'en
parler effectivement de se poser de
questions passionné un peu cette
pratique d'ailleurs on va remercier le
Washington Post de nous éclairer puis
SCP vous Myriam c'est grâce à vous
d'être ce soir ce questionné par exemple
sur est-ce que c'est acceptable qu'on ne
connaissent pas exactement dans quel
cadre se font ces siphonnages de
smartphone de nos vies personnelles
professionnelles est-ce que c'est
acceptable que ces informations soient
détenus pendant 15 ans sans qu'on sache
quelle utilisation en effet et puis
peut-être une autre mesure c'est essayer
de s'en prémunir comme on peut alors il
y a notamment un entrepreneur sur
Twitter vous avez peut-être voir son
poste s'afficher qui invite à changer de
numéro de téléphone quand tu es aux USA
connectez-vous à distance à votre mobile
autrement ce sont vos concurrents qui
auront accès à vos contacts qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'on a de
plus en plus de citoyens finalement qui
commencent à chercher à adopter des
outils utilisés normalement par des
dissidents dans des pays dictatoriaux
donc est-ce que c'est ça qu'on veut faut
quand même se reposer les questions de
la légitimité de toutes ces données qui
sont connectés et puis même de leur
efficacité là encore dans l'article du
Washington Post on rappelle que la NSA
au moment de la révélation par Edward
Snowden de du scandale des écoutes
l'agence de renseignement avec quand
même reconnu le peu d'utilité pour
traquer les terroristes ou lutter contre
la criminalité donc moi je remets pas du
tout en question le sujet sécuritaire la
nécessité d'accéder à des informations
mais je pense que c'est vraiment l'heure
aujourd'hui de revenir à de la mesure
sur ses collectes de données et puis de
la transparence je dirais au moins au
minimum vis-à-vis du législateur ce qui
n'est visiblement pas le cas ici merci
beaucoup d'ailleurs Daniel Cohen vous
avez peut-être lu son livre oui homo
numériqueuse traite également de ces
questions éthiques de régulation des
réseaux sociaux et sera là demain à
votre place on est très loin du
numérique de confiance ça vous inquiète
ça Delphine
cette nuit mais plus sérieusement on
avait l'impression d'être dans une série
comme une de ces séries comme Black
Mirror donc l'impression d'être dans une
dystopie déjà dans lequel nous-monde
nous nous projettent mais effectivement
comme vous dites je pensais essentiel
dans d'en parler et de réfléchir à la
mesure
le numérique les questions éthiques la
protection des données merci merci
Delphine sabadier merci Pierre-Henri
tavoyau Chloé Ridel
idem l'idée donc il n'y a pas de hasard
c'est très court mais c'est vraiment
vraiment un plaisir merci Delphine Henri
Dès d'être venu sur le plateau de LCP
votre soirée documentaire tout de suite
avec Jean-Pierre Gratien bien sûr à
demain belle soirée à vous
[Musique]